in Germany a child is born let's call
her Laura straight away she's in the
care of the church in Germany every
third Hospital is run by a Christian
organization laura is christened in a
Catholic Church she belongs to the
world's largest religious community
Christianity 1.1 billion Christians are
Roman Catholic 800 million are
Protestant and 300 million are Eastern
Orthodox Christianity is a wealthy
religion in the US for example faith
based business contributes more to the
economy than the top 10 technology
businesses churches there are financed
by donations in Germany the Catholic and
Lutheran churches are worth some 345
billion euros they own shares real
estate breweries and even film
production companies over a million
people work for the churches that's
second only to the German state which
employs over 4.5 million Laura goes to
Catholic daycare when she's older she'll
be confirmed and presented with the
world's biggest selling book at least 3
billion copies of the Bible have been
sold to date making it a nice little
earner for publishers as an adult
Laura will pay an additional 9 percent
of her income tax as Church tax although
many have opted to leave the Catholic
and Lutheran churches still saw record
high takings in 2015 of 11.5 billion
euros when Laura dies she wants a
Christian burial and her final resting
place will be in a Catholic cemetery